before we start I've got to be honest
with you about something
um when we recorded this episode with
Mel c
um it was honestly one of the most
moving heartbreaking inspiring revealing
conversations I've ever had on this
podcast and I've been looking forward to
sharing this conversation with you for
some time now
um and then we had an incident where one
of our hard drives was stolen and we
lost the audio for Mel's mic which is
really really heartbreaking because of
all the episodes to lose the audio for
for it to be this one is has been very
hard to deal with and I think I want to
start by apologizing to Mel because she
came here she shared her story in such a
profound vulnerable way and I've carried
the sense of guilt because
um because when people come here not
only are they giving us their time but
they're giving us their story and for
some people
as is the case in this conversation it's
the first time that that story has been
shared in this way so I've been really
struggling with that but because it was
such a profound story and to to make
sure we honor all of that which Mel gave
us by coming here
um we spent a lot of time fixing the the
audio we do have which actually comes
from one of the cameras that's rolling
not from the microphone in front of her
we've worked with a specialist to try
and repair the audio as much as we
possibly can and this is one of the
episodes where I'm asking you for a
favor which is to stay with us I know
it's not always easy to listen to audio
when it's not as crisp as this audio
sounds right now but there's a story
underneath the um lack of clarity in the
audio the lack of Christmas crispness in
the audio that needs to be heard it's
one of the most amazing Stories we've
ever shared
um and so I hope you enjoyed this
episode and we've put many many many
many many many many many many many
measures in place to make sure that we
never lose any audio or any footage ever
again
in this case it was out of our control
but um
this episode is worth it so we're
putting it out anyway
you're gonna enjoy it there's an element
of guilt attached to my success it was
join us do you know because I had a
secret and it was killing me
[Music]
early days of the Spice Girls were the
best and I feel blessed but with it has
been some really tough times it was
[ __ ] dramatic how it went out
the tablet media were burrito we all got
called a terrible horrible things
did you notice a change in yourself at
all after that definitely that was the
Catalyst why I became very very ill I
couldn't control my eating I was
struggling to get out of bed it's
killing me
[Music]
I think
did becoming famous ruin my life does it
ruin me
sometimes I question
um
yeah
without further Ado I'm Stephen Bartlett
and this is the Diary of a CEO I hope
nobody's listening but if you are then
please keep this to yourself
[Music]
when I when I sit here with people I'm I
I always try and figure out the best
starting point I always know I'm going
to start at the very beginning but with
you when I was reading through your
story it was quite clear to me that
the things that shaped you started at a
very very young age I'm talking when you
were two three and four years old so can
you take me right back to the very start
I'm guessing that's like sort of
1976-ish it is and you're right you know
things that happen to me when I was a
toddler really defined a lot of who I
became I grew up just outside Liverpool
and I was born in Western Hospital my
parents and I lived in a place called
Vine Hill and they divorced when I was I
think I was about three years old
and my life kind of quite quickly
changed you know as lots of young people
would be affected like that and yeah
that was where the story began I think
me developing this need to succeed
when you say your life changed give me a
color to what that means for you so I
was living quite comfortably with mum
and dad you know the kind of happy
archetypal family life and my mum and we
left me and my mum left and we went to
live with my grandparents and then we we
went to live
um in quite a different area we were
still only about 30 minutes away but it
was quite different we went into
um Council accommodation and
my um quite quickly my mum was in a new
relationship so there was this new guy
around and it was just kind of it just
you know looking back it was just very
different it's to the world I'd entered
into when I first turned upon this
planet
what was your um your family's sort of
economic situation throughout this
journey was it were you a working class
family or absolutely yeah I mean my
family still are you know very working
class you know through the generations
and my mum and dad were doing you know
they were doing good we had a lovely
semi-attached house in a in a nice
suburb of you know Liverpool and
obviously with my mum leaving dad as
today you know lots of couples find that
it is very difficult to to start again
um so we were yeah going into a
situation where it was hard for mum to
make ends meet so it was yeah it was it
was quite a tough area to be um to be
growned up in where was your dad
so dad was still in the house in the
house you'd been raised in for those
first few years and then after I think a
couple of years he went traveling and
um yeah and then he went to work abroad
actually so I've always seen a lot of my
dad but there were periods of times when
he was away so
um yeah so it was a bit of a shake-up
quite early because the formative years
aren't they when you're that little you
don't think about it because as a child
your life is your life but I think when
you start to think about who you are and
how you became that person you start to
you just kind of pinpoint maybe little
moments that put you on that track
so when you look back to that that
experience of your parents separating at
a very young age and then you're life
shifting and
um in hindsight what impact did that
have on you like when you look back and
connect those dots and go oh that that's
the reason for that
I think it kind of confused me I think
as a young person to have my location
change you know to be taken from the
family home and obviously all the time
so I didn't understand you know I didn't
understand adult relationships I didn't
understand why it was happening
so this little series of events and then
that you know I have a new I've got a
stepdad and then I had a new sibling and
then I had Step Brothers and so there
was just there was just quite a lot of
big things happening in my little world
and it made me just kind of confused to
like
where I belonged who I was how I fitted
in to that new Dynamic and you know as I
got older and my dad remarried and I
have this incredible family it's very
complicated and it's huge and I have
half siblings and step siblings and step
parents and and it's lovely but I think
for me being the only child of my mum
and dad sometimes made me feel a little
bit of a spare part
and I think that's what made me feel
like I had to make myself a place in the
world my own place in the world and I
think also it was about kind of earning
the love of these people I kind of felt
like I had to prove that I was worthy of
existence it sounds melodramatic but I
think as a as a young person you I mean
especially going through my teenage
years you question everything don't you
you know why I'm here and a lot of that
for me was like do I deserve to be here
and so I had to make myself worthy of
being here and you think that started
because of the your parents separation
and in this new context of these other
siblings that were felt maybe belonged
more than yeah I I think I think
especially when you know both my parents
remarried and they're both really
happily remarried and have gone on to
have more children
and I love my parents and I love my
stepparents and all of my siblings
but for me I sometimes feel quite alone
and I think that it is what propelled me
and some of the issues I went on to have
in later life you know for good and for
bad you know I think there's been real
benefits to those feelings and to make
me very determined
um very conscientious but also it's
going to be very hard on myself and a
little bit of a perfectionist
one of the things that I was quite
surprised to read was this almost
contradiction between you you really
looked up to your dad
you I think you wrote your book that you
almost worshiped him but then when he
left it was almost like there wasn't
there wasn't a reaction from you yeah
I know it's so strange to me
it's hard when you're that young isn't
it because your own memories are such
little tiny Snippets and you remember
and we all remember things but for my
dad you know I did I put him on a
pedestal and I still do you know he's my
hero and he always will be oh yeah he
ran away and he went away for his own
reasons and as an adult completely
understand that you know and he needed
to do that
but yeah I kind of shut down I think and
I think I kind of I have learned in my
life which has been really useful in my
career that I can have these incredibly
intense emotional feelings
but they have to be
buried
not help me
but helpful sometimes
in the short term yeah yeah but I think
if you if your knowledge you know you
have the knowledge that you do that I
think that can help
and just maybe not doing it or or trying
to
not do it
is that the first time you you kind of
recall that those early years where you
think you might have just buried a set
of emotions and not addressed them that
that blocking out of it just to keep on
keeping on yeah I think I I think some
of it is my personality but I think some
of it was circumstance
kind of I
I don't I don't want to cause people
problems I want to always make sure
everybody's okay
um and I think that's a lot to do with
worthiness
you know feeling unworthy potentially
um just just so I'm completely clear in
my own mind because I I don't want to
make any assumptions that feeling of
like not feeling worthiness came from
that dysfunctional family Dynamic that's
the first sort of hint you have of it I
I think so I think looking back you know
I grew up in the 70s and 80s and
for me in environment I was in I was at
time it was
it was about parents separated all of my
friendship group they had to me what I
saw as their happy family you know the
family unit and I longed for that and I
didn't have that and it made me
different and obviously you know if I
forwarded today and I think it's
probably rarer to have the family humid
you know life has changed so much so
that's how it affected me at the time it
made me feel like yeah an outsider and a
bit strange
you moved to um runcorn with your mother
which is um where the council estate is
where you lived
what that area isn't a good area back
then yeah you know I mean runcorn is
it's like a satellite town of Liverpool
and lots of people you know it's kind of
like over spill and lots of people were
out there in this this particular estate
that we we got housed in was it was
built and it was obviously there were so
many families I needed to be housed very
much like today
and it was this oh like a bizarre
architecture and we had these huge round
windows in these little houses about I
used to call them the Lego houses
because they were like blue and yellow
it was you know I suppose at the time it
seemed very forward thinking but I think
unfortunately you know it was it was one
of those environments of which there
were still many
um were you know problems can occur
because it's it's kind of set up there
are
you know there are just opportunities I
suppose for people to be quite discreet
and there was you know lots of people
there who were struggling and it was I
think it was knocked down I think they
started knocking it down in about 1980
because it just kind of got yeah
to run down I think when you um when you
look back on your father's decision to
leave is there any feelings of like
I don't know
animosity towards that decision to for
him to leave your life I understand the
separation but for him to then be absent
seems like it was from reading your book
The Catalyst moment for other things to
then happen has there ever been any
animosity towards when you reflected on
it as you grew up no really no that
really hasn't because I think you know
just that thing of being a kid and your
life is your life you know so it's just
that you get killed something like oh
okay then and I think when I became a
parent and I think about my daughter and
obviously I work away a lot you know
um but I just
yeah it's it's weird I don't think you
really fully I didn't you ever fully
understand your parents but I think you
get a much better understanding of them
when you become a parent you know but at
the end of the day I think as a child
you look up to these adults thinking you
know they know how everything should be
and how everything should be done and
then when you become an adult you're
like you know I'm 50 in a year and a
half and I still haven't got a clue so
and I still feel like a child you know
and my mum says I feel like a teenager
um can I get that now we're all just
trying to figure it out throughout our
lives you know I don't think we ever get
to that age where we go yeah I've got it
now
dancing
seemed to be your first love as I was
reading through your story where did
that show up where did Dancing come from
you know I think like so many young kids
you have this moment where you may go to
ballet or disco or whatever the local
you know is in the the local club or
whatever and I went on to ballet and tap
when I was so little I can't even
remember but it must have shook a chord
with me because when we moved to runcorn
it was there was no way one could afford
for me to do dance classes so I had this
period of time without it
we moved to witness when I was I think I
was eight years old and that's when I
picked up dancing again and I think I'd
really like bugged my mum for years I
want to go I think I didn't want to go
back I want to go back and I did Sports
at school you know I've always I'm just
very active I'm I think was probably one
of those kids who never sat still you
know I was always outside I was always
upside down or kicking a ball or
something and dancing for me it was just
a way of expressing myself and a freedom
and it was almost like a safe place
safe place like many performers and I'm
sure you've spoken to people who are
like this but that I'm quite shy in
certain aspects of my life maybe like in
a social aspect and you know being at
school like getting my head down I
wasn't very academic I did okay but when
I was dancing when I was doing something
creative and being able to express
myself I felt very confident and free
and alive so yeah dancing school was
where I really felt in my element so so
you became
a very obsessive
dancer practicer very meticulous yeah I
think
the ballet and the training of that
and it just really works for me and and
even now you know I have to have an
awareness of this that it's to have
those parameters and to have that
discipline makes me feel safe
I don't really know where that comes
from
but I am I'm very hard on myself and I
kind of I think I'm a little bit of a
workaholic because I feel like when I'm
in a workspace and I'm being very
disciplined that I'm safe
one might guess that um if parameters
and discipline and that structure makes
you feel safe then there might have been
a time where a lack of parameters made
you feel unsafe
or a lack of a foundation made you feel
unsafe absolutely I'm sure I'm sure I
think there was a lot of you know my
mum's a performer and you know it's it's
so it's so weird now because obviously I
find myself in in a similar position but
she'd be away an awful lot but there'd
be times when I'd be staying with other
people or you know having babysitters
and you know maybe there was a little
bit of instability felt there and that
would definitely make sense a bit of
instability is this are you talking to
talking about your nanny
yeah yeah there was a little
um
you know she felt was was a great person
for well but unfortunately you know the
girl she was maybe a little bit too
young to take on that responsibility and
had kind of moved me out of our home and
I've moved in with with her mum and uh
yeah it was all a little bit Shady but
yeah as soon as mum found out she put an
end to it but I think I was very quiet
about it because I was so little I think
I was only about five
so um I chose not to tell her probably
didn't want to rock the boat what were
you telling her
um that I wasn't at home and that I
wasn't being taken care of by the girl
she'd employed to take care of me
that feels like uh
a light way of saying something that is
a little less light in reality well you
know again I was so young it was I don't
think it was until I got older that I
thought that's
that was probably something that would
affect you in a big way but at the time
it was just my life you recite this
moment of just waiting for this per this
person that was meant to be taking care
of you
um just not showing up on many occasions
and you having to wait outside and
weighing your pants at one point because
you were waiting outside so long yeah I
remember getting back from school and we
had these new horrible damn concrete
steps up to their flat door and no one
was home and yeah just busting for the
toilet and yeah I wet myself and luckily
the neighbor came home and she took me
in and kind of cleaned me up and
yeah so that's I mean again I was so
young there's there's just these little
flushes of memories of those things I
think I think when you're when you're
young you maybe don't it's not that
those I think about my own life like
it's not that those things don't aren't
impacting you it's you don't you're not
really aware of the impact they're
having or the stories that they're
they're making you write about yourself
and about your situation
um and then obviously often times it
seems that we including myself then see
the consequences of it and in hindsight
have to sort of piece together where
that came from but that's I mean when I
when I read that
um in your book I was
I mean that's that's almost like
criminal negligence to treat a child in
such a way and I think about the your
the departure of your father your mum
then departing to go and pursue her
career and then you you're ultimately
ending up on these steps you know
urinating your underwear because
of this negligent uh nanny
and that's you know that that's where I
think oh that is you know that must have
been formative in to some to some degree
yeah I mean you know I'm a good believer
in therapy and I've been having it for
many years
um probably I only started to do that
because of
my time with the Spice Girls and how
much of a head [ __ ] that was but it's
really interesting because
you do look at your habits and the
things that you do and why you do them
and so much of it comes back to your
childhood
dancing was your first love
um you you become very disciplined at
that and eventually
off you go to
um study in London and that's where you
find singing yeah
which you hadn't had you been doing it
before you know because my mum was a
singer
and she had deals in the 70s she had a
couple of record deals with different
bands but you know it hadn't worked out
the way she would have liked it to
um you know she did great but didn't get
to those Heights that all of us
performed together
so I just knew growing up it's really
really hard working in the music
industry is really difficult
so you know my young brain goes okay I
want to be a pop star
but
it's really hard so I love dancing and I
love singing so theater because I loved
musical theater as well
I went to perform regards college and I
was pursuing that and I'd sung a little
bit but I just I never really had
confidence in my voice but there was
this like weird thing of
it just gave me so much joy
actually more joy than dancing
I was in college I was in my second year
and we had these competitions that would
happen every year and I was singing a
song and it was the first time I just
had a moment with an audience where they
I just really felt this energy this
transaction between myself and them and
it was when I was singing and it that
was it for me that was the moment it was
like it is singing that is it that is
what I have to do
So eventually you um un 400 other
young women
respond to a advert in a magazine what
was that advert okay so what I so the
stage newspaper was when you leave
perform regards College you're an actor
a dancer singer whatever you're going
for your auditions the stage is where
you find your auditions find myself an
audition I didn't want to be out handed
a flyer for a girl band
and I'm like that's it and that's what
I'm gonna do
you get handed a flyer a lot of people
are being handed that flyer
did you know then that you would you
said that's it that's what I want to do
did you know then that you wanted to be
in a girl band or did you mean that's it
I'm gonna apply and I think that's more
befitting of what I where I want to go
it's hard
no exactly
yeah of course but my telling of the
story is I mean I just had a really
strong feeling at that time that I was
gonna whatever this thing was I was
going to be a part of it and it was
going to be something incredible what
did that fly say
I think it said something like are you
18 to 24 I think it was like the wording
of it Street wise can dancing fun-loving
I don't know but it was yeah it was just
basically an audition an open audition
anyone come along we're putting a girl
band together okay music management and
yeah I went along to that audition
and how did that go it went well I was
recalled we had to dance and then we we
called to sing and then we were all sent
away and then we were we were called
back
but when we were called back I was ill
and I couldn't speak let alone sing so
um yeah I I missed my first opportunity
of being in this band
you missed your first opportunity yeah
so I was really sick I kept getting
tonsillitis and I yeah I was really
poorly when the recall happened and so I
begged my mum to call him and just say
good Melanie week like I bet he should
come and sing for you but they were like
no we've already chosen the girls it's
I'm afraid you know it's to know this
town and there was lots of auditions
that were now so it was like oh well it
wasn't meant to be but then a couple of
weeks after that I got called to say
somebody hasn't worked out we'd like to
see Melanie again
and then that was my chance to get in
the band
Christ
that is a pivotal phone call
you know I think I
actually because that still wasn't the
five that everybody got to know you know
there was I think there were three girls
from the the beginning of the band being
put together who didn't end up being
part of the final lineup of the Spice
Girls
it's funny that when you think back even
being handed that flyer you think
what path would I have walked
potentially
if that person that day hadn't given me
that flyer it's a really strange thought
isn't it I guess the sliding doors
moment isn't it but it's like yeah I
really because often in interviews
you'll be asked oh if you didn't do this
if you do and I'm like I have no clue
it's funny I think about it because I
there was an early early point of my
career where I got a phone call saying
um a day before saying the 16 year old
kid that was meant to be speaking at
this event had dropped out last minute
and could I get to London I had no money
I end up um bunking on the Mega Bus this
16 year old kid had just sold his
business for 30 million so they needed
like a young entrepreneur last minute
found me because I was on some website
3am asked me to come and that sent me
off in my career it was where I got my
investors from that one talk I think if
they hadn't asked me to be there how
would my life have been different
um and the weird thought which we never
consider is that
maybe I would have been happier
have you ever have you ever thought that
often often yeah you know I I wouldn't
change my life obviously I'm so proud of
the things that I've achieved and I have
an incredible life and I absolutely do
my passion you know that's my I've just
had a weekend of it you know three shows
over the weekend and I feel blessed but
with it has been some really tough times
and sometimes I do I do think wow
I think
did becoming famous ruin my life
did it ruin me
sometimes I question that
it's a hard one to answer isn't it
because you don't know the Alternatives
so you can't yeah but I think the thing
is it's like you know it's always so
important isn't it
we're on a journey
what's the destination the destination
is death
you know we've just got to enjoy this
journey and I remember the early days of
the Spice Girls were the best before we
released anything we had the most fun
because it was this excitement what's
going to happen you know what could it
be and then when it happened it was
incredible but there's a lot of brushes
that come along with it so everything
starts to change
in those early years then so before
you've released any music you stumbled
around trying to find management for a
while right
and then you recount stories in your
book about some like [ __ ] that's
made some just like awful comments to
you can you tell me about that that
comment I was his name chick oh chick
yeah so he was a financial backer so
when we we were first put together by a
management team and we were with them
maybe for about a year and chick was
um yeah the financial backer of these
original managers and he'd commented on
the size of my thighs and which was
something that really shook me because
you know I went to a performing arts
college which was predominantly a
dancing in college and you know the body
image was an issue there there was there
were girls with eating disorders I'd
been
you know I'd been witness to that in my
life but yeah it never affected me
personally
um you know and I'm a teenager put on a
little bit away moving away from home
not really eating as well going down the
pub and you know so my weight fluctuated
a little bit but it was never something
that really bothered me it was just yeah
I'll cut back a little bit lose a few
pounds but somebody actually commenting
on the way I looked when I was going
into a career where so much of it is
about how you look really affected me
did he make that comment in front of
people he made that comment in front of
the other girls
there's something about there's
something about
um when you're trying to fit in when
someone points at something which makes
you different or that might make you
feel like you don't fit in and from just
listening to your early years where
fitting in and feeling worthy was so
important to you for someone to then in
a group of people where you where you
belong those that that band to say this
is why you don't fit essentially with
that comment
I can't think of anything more more
hurtful for one's self-esteem especially
as a young person because you know think
I think like I was probably 19 at that
point
which at the time you feel like you are
grown up in that college going out into
the Big Wide World
you're a child you know you're still so
young and so vulnerable well Victoria
said to you that he had said comments to
her about her weight as well or her
appearance yeah I think you know it was
it was very much at that time I mean I
you know I went to dance college so
teachers would say you need to lose
weight you know what's that stomach
there I mean I've spoken to dancers
recently about the culture of that
because you know um recently there was a
lot there's been a lot talked about in
the gymnastics world oh yeah and
there was definitely a culture within
dance which was very cruel and heartless
and shaming body shaming
um which is changing but you know dance
teachers there are some really lovely
nurturing ones out there but some of the
best dance teachers are horrible you
know we I mean
carrot in the stick it's quite an
old-fashioned way but
it worked in some ways but it's very
damaging did it change your behavior
that that comment from him did you
notice a change in yourself at all after
that definitely that was the Catalyst
there was a catalyst for me to it was
like a wake-up call it was like
if I want to do this if I'm going to be
a pop star and you have to remember this
was like the 90s as well so it was you
know body image was a very different
thing there you know thank God there's
so much more body positivity now you
know but back then it was all about
being stick then
and I thought well if I'm gonna do this
I have to fit the mold and so then that
was it was just it was it was a gradual
thing but it was like the eating and the
exercising and that's when that's when
it began yeah from a comment like that
which he probably
didn't give a second thought to you know
isn't that crazy it's crazy
we never really appreciate that one
comment can have such a profound impact
and change someone's
um the trajectory of their health or
their well-being in such a significant
way just one comment yeah just a few
words yeah you know I think it's a bit
of a trigger isn't it you know so that
happened
and I think obviously I was feeling
vulnerable in
it knocks your confidence but then it's
kind of I think it's like a little chain
of events that leads you down that road
right you know
so that maybe was the little start of it
it ignited about the first Domino before
yeah yeah on that Journey trying to find
New Management you you stumbled across
Simon Cowell as well and he
he must hate when you recount this story
because oh it's so funny because he this
is the thing right everybody remembers
things differently because he remembers
he said yes to us but we said no to him
so basically we got to the point where
we were going to record companies we
were looking for a record deal so we
left the original management
and we had some demos demo tapes and we
were going around meeting managers
meeting record labels and most people
were very positive we got very positive
reactions but we remember Simon saying
he wasn't interested in us
um yeah but he recounts it differently
so that's funny isn't it because
obviously then it was the 90s he was a
record company exactly he wasn't known
to the to the wider public at this point
when you're going around trying to find
management how are you like providing
for yourselves how where's the money
coming from to sustain the band and was
there ever a moment where you thought
[ __ ] this I'm gonna no no no so when we
were with our original management they
they did give us like a little bit of
pocket money they put us up in a house I
think they gave us about 60 pounds a
week which because we weren't paying for
our accommodation at the time you know
we could make ends meet
um but when we left them I think I went
to stay with a friend back in sukup
where I've been to college so I was like
staying in her spare room and then there
was a period of time where Melanie and
Jerry were homeless they were doing a
little bit sofa surfing yeah and Emma
went home to her mum's place in Finchley
and Victoria was back at air mum's place
up
um in Hertfordshire so yeah we were and
it was think this I remember we go to
Emma's mum's place
and she'd do loads of toast for us and
wrapping tin foil and that would be
breakfast and yeah we were just we never
thought it was never an option to give
up we were on this journey and we were
going to make it happen
how long was that period when between
you leaving your initial management to
ultimately when you found Simon Fuller
and you know that kind of it began with
Virgin how long was that how big was
that Gap it wasn't as long as a year
okay with an Elio maybe about eight
months or so but we we had um somebody
who was you know very kindly looking
after us so what we've done before we
left our original management we talked
our original management into putting on
a showcase okay so we did that and then
we met some writers and producers and
Publishers and we made some contacts and
we kind of knew already we were going to
leave but we just thought let's get this
out of them and we did that and so we
pursued that and we were with Mark Fox
who was head of publishing at BMG at the
time and he kind of took us under his
wing and would take us out for dinners
and he'd got us to meet people and that
kind of got us on our road
success and then you met Simon Fuller
talk to me about that and how'd that
change things yeah it was really
interesting because we'd been it's so
funny isn't it we really did take
matters into our own hands and we talk
about auditioning managers you know we
were this unknown girl band everyone was
telling us governments don't work but we
were out there going right is this
manager good enough for us
um so we just we just had this attitude
that we've got something very special
and we're not going to undersell it or
ourselves and which is wonderful you
know even if any of us have any doubts
about it we were like no this is the way
it is and I think that real
determination single-mindedness is a
really important part of succeeding it's
like no there's no doubt this will not
fail so we went out there and met these
people and Mark Fox was introducing us
to songwriters we've met Martin Biff who
he wrote wannabe and Two Become One it'd
be forever and we also met absolute who
we wrote who do you think you are too
much with those guys
and they were managed by a guy called
Pete and he was in Simon's offices
and Simon heard the music and wanted to
meet us so he was the first person who
approached us
and eventually you sign with virgin
virgin virgin virgin records yeah we
gave everyone the run around and we got
the money up and up and up and up as you
could in those days and we just loved
virgin it was an incredible team and we
just had so much fun with them they
really shared our vision great a r
Ashley Newton you know obviously spice
was such a great album as his Spice
World
um so yeah it was like a match made in
heaven you you recount that moment that
Simon Fuller gave you your first
um 10K check I believe and this is
before you've released any music right
so this is like is this a signing bonus
so we got like um you get a advance when
you you know when you examsia not so
much these days it's changed so much but
yeah you get in advance and we hadn't
seen like what we would deem as properly
and that was proper money I've got all
those zeros what did you do with it
um I think you know what I did with my
first one no I don't you're not okay I
just think I did I do know you went
awesome
I mean I saw that check right yeah
I can I remember like being like on this
kind of stairwell in this party give me
a check ten thousand pounds
I went down to Oxford Street Jetty
Sports and I bought the Nike Air Max
that I've been like get I've had my eye
on for weeks I've made it and what did
you do with the rest Stephen the bank
what did I do with the rest I think I
paid for some driving lessons
um yeah I paid for my event and I mean
pretty much when you you get in advance
whether it's with the Rebecca company or
publishing it's your living expenses you
know and you're a young artist and
you've not released anything that's kind
of what it goes on how quickly did
things move from the point of getting
that check on that stairwell to
um wannabe the first single
taking off how how quickly was that
gosh are you you're really
testing my memory now I think
I want to say it was around Christmas
time when we when we got the check
and then wannabe was released in July of
96. so maybe about six months six months
it's not it's not very long time is it
it's not and it's from what I read the
wannabe didn't take a long time to
record either
is definitely under half an hour this is
we kind of disagree with it 15 minutes
was it 20 minutes I mean it was kind of
thrown together it was was it ever going
to be a song we weren't sure we were
just kind of being silly and Matt and
both who are incredible just obviously
made it into something which it went to
number one in 37 countries I mean I
don't think I even knew there was 37
countries
that's crazy yeah what what does that
feel like so you release that single
then you start getting the the murmurs
the noise the the world starts vibrating
a little bit what is that what is that
like
well we had big Ideas we probably had
big Ideas above our station before we
should have done but it helped us our
original manager were always like don't
get too big for your boots you know you
haven't done anything yet you need
you've got work to do we know we've got
work to do but we've got something
special and we are going to make this
happen
so we were always like we felt we were
very important and very special
and when other people started to think
that too wannabe was released it was
still early days but we released our
album in Japan because at the time there
was no internet so artists would release
music in different territories at
different times so you could kind of
catch up with yourself with your promo
you were able to do it I'd like to say
you had time to do it but hey there's
only seven days in a week our schedule
was insane
but we started in Japan and one of you
went to number one why we were in Japan
so we didn't really get a sense of what
was happening at home and I think when
we flew back to the UK we were in Japan
for about two weeks
when we when we flew back everything had
changed
and that was it when it was when people
really did start recognizing Us in the
Stream
yeah it all started to
yeah increase at that point and how did
that feel at first it was so exciting it
was kind of like it's almost like you
put in a like in a catapult you know
we've been we'd be doing all this about
doing all this way you know and then
you're gone and you're just on this act
oh and it really was
I I was trying to make sure I had the
dates right before because when I was
looking at the the amount of time from
that first single to the number one
albums and the meteoric global super
stardom it feels like this much time I
was like I'm sure I've got the dates
wrong there must be like a decade like
typo somewhere because it was just a
couple of years
it's not even a full two years right one
of these released in July 1997.
Jeremy left the band in the spring of 98
when we were two shows short of our
European leg of the tour
so it wasn't a full two years that the
five
were together doing the thing you know
it's that's mad I don't understand that
right we got together in 94 that's when
we all first met so together a couple of
years beforehand but yeah by 98 Springer
98 Jerry had gone we went on to do our
U.S leg of the tours of four piece we
come back Melanie and Victoria had their
babies so obviously everything started
to change by that point it was a very
different chapter in the lives of this
horoscope at that moment in my head the
Spice Girls
weren't like two decades
yeah maybe that's why maybe the music
lasted obviously but uh but when I was
reading that was like two years I was
like what how is that possible how is
two two um two albums
and a movie
and I will tell and yeah and all those
MTV music videos that were playing in my
house constantly because of my sister
um
but I had to listen to a cup the odd CD
when no one was in the house but
that's why podcast we can edit that out
um but but when you think about why you
were success because there were a lot of
other girl bands at that time and there
were even other girl bands that had a
similar fundamental messages of
empowerment and as you you call it girl
power I think you can't say that anymore
I think that's a bit of a people don't
like using me using the word girl but um
girl power and feminism and female
empowerment why in hindsight do you
think that you broke through
um and and these others who were there
before you and in some situations were
much better placed
why did you win
I think the stars were in alignment
whatever the magic was with that Dynamic
that we are so different that we are
quite strong in our individuality
that we made the decision to address how
we each felt comfortable you know girl
bands before us had coordinated their
look or had a certain look and we
realized that didn't work for us
we wanted to make pop music we loved pop
music we love so many genres but we felt
like there was a space for a female band
you know we kind of looked at bands like
take that and New Kids on the Block and
there was no girl bands doing that and
that's what we wanted to do and I just
think just all those little elements a
lot of them accidental you know are
nicknames which we never came up with it
wasn't a marketing idea it was top of
the pops magazine Peter Levine who was
edited there at the time just thought
it'd be really fun to give us some
nicknames and they stuck and they became
part of the brand you know and they
still live on to this day I mean in the
US we're known mainly by our nicknames
so
yeah like the stars like I say it feels
like they were just in alignment it was
meant to be we had this idea that
something was going to happen but I
think it was raining Stars
timing seems to be quite um important in
hindsight as well when you think about
where the world was was it ready for
this message was it ready for a band
like this
um because you know if you'd been maybe
10 years earlier maybe it wouldn't have
worked out or 10 years later
but there's it's funny the the case of
timing and then even when you think back
to being handed that flyer the timing of
that and it's quite
serendipitous and you know the butterfly
effect of just these
these things linking up and
can be quite spooky yeah it really is
you know you're right at the time it's
over the 90s it was a period of growth
in the UK you know it was quite a
positive time for the country we just
kind of come out of the grungies
musically
um Indy was big here and you know we
can't
you know say oh you know oh you're
welcome female empowerment yes we
brought that this was something that was
bubbling and moving and changing and we
were just really fortunate that we hit
it at a time when more and more people
were getting on it you know
um and I think because you know people
often talk about feminism with the Spice
Girls and it's like we feel like you
know we were young
we had a point to prove we wanted to be
a girl band for girls and we wanted to
talk about female empowerment and how
girls could do whatever they wanted to
do no one was telling us we couldn't do
something and it enabled us to take
feminism and make it more you know
palatable to a younger audience you know
we had fans of three years of age a pop
band or a music act had never had that
before you know and even now you know
it's amazing I do these shows and I go
out and I do solo stuff and I do a
couple of Spice Girl songs and there's
so many young kids in the audience
loving and real discovering the Spice
Girls and it's it's incredible it still
captures their imagination
that um that pressure though people
often talk about the pressure of being
in a band but the pressure of being in a
girl band at that time especially when
even you know the media were very
vicious and there wasn't an awareness
around the impact of words on mental
well-being and how that can impact
people
um strikes me as being an even more
difficult time than today of being in
well we have social media now which is
also an exacerbating Factor but talk to
me about the the pressure of public
scrutiny back then on young women
you're right you know the Tabloid media
were brutal I think things have improved
not that much I mean it is quite
shocking now when I look back over
articles from the 90s and naughties just
like the wording that was used I think
they're just a bit more sneaky with it
now you know they're still saying the
same things but in a slightly different
way but back then it was just brutal I
mean I got called we all got called
like terrible horrible things
and as a young person
I think for anyone and you're right you
know the generation now have social
media to deal with it which I think is
equally as damaging if not more so in
many ways because you can't escape it
can you you know your phone is there I
wake up first thing I do look at my
phone
um luckily now I have the skin of a
rhino so if anyone's saying anything
negative about me
um you know I can I can usually push out
but yeah back then it was I was trying
to figure out because I was you know who
am I these people are telling me I'm
this thing you know they're criticizing
me um I'm not talented enough I'm not
pretty enough I'm stupid I'm a loud
mouth and this and it's like who am I am
I who I want to be Am I who they tell me
I am should I be who they want me to be
and it's so confusing and that was I
think another you know we were talking
about these different elements that got
me because I became very very ill
um around 2000 and you know the the
eating and the exercising and from
chicks words and certain things that had
happened being photographed constantly
but being commented on constantly was a
big factor in that Journey
you didn't mean to change when I took
when I mentioned that
it looked like it genuinely I could I
could see how that that phase of your
life had impacted you just from the the
change in your
um
yeah it's
[Music]
I don't think anyone can ever you know
it's really hard you know because
I'm always in this place where
visit
I'm always in this place where
there's an element of guilt attached to
my success and I think that's
exacerbated by people going were you
famous
you know you put yourself in that
position
and something I explore in the book is
you know people who want to be famous
probably other people at least one quick
to do with it because you know we're
we're looking for accepting and love
an adoration and to be that vulnerable
and to put yourself in that position
only to be criticized is it's a bad
combination and I think you know with
the table of media as it was back then
I mean it's terrific I mean I've looked
again recently because you know that
there's been certain reasons why I've
been having to read old articles on
myself and I'm shocked
I am I mean I don't want to jump forward
too far with the story but I I did
suffer with
a couple of Eating Disorders one of them
being binge eating disorder I was very
depressed and I gained some weight
because I've been underweight for a long
long time
and my body was just like it was just a
reaction it was like I am starved of any
nourishments yeah but heal me feed me
and you know obviously the big change in
that make me gain weight and it wasn't
an enormous amount of weight I think I
went from the size probably about a size
I suppose it just sounds like a lot if
you sell like a size six to a size 14
but then a size 14 I don't think it's
even the average size of women in the UK
and they called me Sumo space
I mean how disgusting is that
so whoever this person is I'm not going
to say it's a guy maybe it was maybe it
wasn't the editor probably was but they
thought it was appropriate to call a
young woman who actually had been open
because she kind of thought she had to
be
about her issues and it was okay to call
her Sumo space
how sick is that it's really [ __ ] up
isn't it
I mean worst thing will happen to people
and you know where things happen in the
world but in this in my world at that
time when that happened it was
devastating
gosh it's disgusting isn't it they
couldn't do it now
they couldn't do that now but like I say
they it's all a little bit reading
between the lines now isn't it
you were so young then as well you were
you know you're in your teen years but
you're still a child at that age and as
you say learning who you are and what
you mean was there a moment where you
realized that so that first comment from
chick sends you changes your behavior
was there a moment where you look back
on and go
that was maybe this not the second
Catalyst moment but my behavior took a
really sharp turn there in terms of like
exercise and obsessing over food and
fitting in yeah I think it was it was
more when we were in the public eye
being a photograph doing lots of photo
shoots
um yeah you know some of it is linked to
a need of control isn't it because
things at that point felt very much out
of our control even though we you know
we wanted to take
this thing you know in our own hands and
we wanted to make it happen
um I think because when things with the
Spice Girls became Uber successful which
was very quick after the release of
wannabe were flying all over the world
you're in a bubble you know this crazy
bubble and it's great you're having an
amazing time but you can't you can't do
things on your own terms anymore
but you can control what you put in your
mouth or you can be in the gym where
people will leave you alone because I
don't don't bother if she's in the gym
you write about how you turn into a
robot
what do you mean by robot
Okay so
I think
I found it the only way I could survive
D the experience was by switching off my
feelings
um
I had to eat a certain way I had to
exercise a certain amount and I couldn't
not do it so I had to switch off any of
those like human emotions or any of
those just even listening to my own body
this there was a task that had to be
done and I had to complete it
and the robot and let's do it and that
was kind of my inner dialogue
and you recount this um this day of risk
reciting some reciting that well-being
on a running machine which I found very
almost quite unnerving and quite strange
looking in the mirror and telling
yourself that you're a robot yeah
yeah that actually happened you were
looking
I can
remember kind of in the middle of a Road
Travelers and yeah that was that was my
way of coping because like shut down
shut off just like just this body is
just a piece of Machinery that will do
what it has to do
and there was no there was no choice
that was the thing there was no choice
that was the way it had to be and it
wasn't until I had which by you know I I
imagine was a break in 2000 when I just
you know I hit that bottom and and
that's
when I kind of fell apart because the
robot wasn't working anymore
have you when you think back of that
young girl
have you got how do you feel about her
as an as an as an you know much more
mature person now how did you feel about
that young girl that was going through
that
family stops before
I feel like you know it was
the most incredible time of my life
and the hardest
and as much as I enjoyed it it was
jobless you know because I had a secret
and I was dealing with what I had to
deal with
I'm living my dream at the same time it
was it's a it's a head [ __ ] is what it
is because I wouldn't change anything
I changed that I changed that I became
the victim of an eating disorder in
exercising obsessively I wish that
hadn't happened to me so I could have
fully enjoyed the wonderful things that
happened to me 100
you know life isn't perfect there's
always issues there's always things we
have to overcome but it was
[ __ ] dramatic in
how it went down
what would you say to her if you could
speak to her I say sorry
I do I feel so sorry but I did that to
him
yeah I think I've been angry as well I
think I've ain't anger at other people
but I think as an adult you have to take
responsibility for your actions
um
you know I don't understand bitterly
Twisted but don't you know there were
people
oh you know
the Tabloid media I don't want a victim
learn about the tablet media but you
know they probably need to be bitched
and learned about because they've been
disgraced
um
but yeah I just I I feel sorry
I feel regretful
well what would you say sorry to her for
if I pointed through that I think her
through that for and it feels like
I kind of I have a lot of guilt attached
to
what I was representing but what was
really going on behind closed doors and
you know what I'm such an honest person
I can't I can't lie I'm so bad at lying
and I I feel so dishonest if I'm not
burying myself to people but I was
living life
and that's probably the hardest part of
it
that um
that secret the secret you're referring
to is the eating disorder and the
obsessive exercising right the secret
you were keeping when you say um eating
disorder are you referring to the binge
eating disorder that was did that come
after that was later yeah okay so
you know the weird thing is actually as
you as you put it like that it's like I
was in denial
you know because there is a little voice
that goes
you can't carry around like this but
then the other voice the bigger voice
goes you haven't got a choice
and the first season of disorder I I
started to
um just to eat less small potions and
then I started to eliminate food groups
um to a point because I was terrified of
that and then I was terrified of cops
and then I wouldn't eat a banana because
it's got too much sugar in it I mean I
do not even know how I survived and I
think often now I get so exhausted I
think it's probably through years of
being malnourished
um I lived on fruit and vegetables for
about two years
and I was underweight my period stopped
you know I kind of I've always wanted to
be a mum
but I had no choice but to live this
life I was living and I was jeopardizing
the chance of being a mum I mean how
crazy is that
just this compulsion
and then it all comes to a head in 2000
when um
you hate their bodies you know we oh I
hate this oh you should get asked in
interviews but you know what what's your
favorite what would you call them like
your favorite attribute or whatever you
know what what do you what do you like
least about yourself you know what
[Music]
[ __ ] questions why would you why
would you ever say never be negative in
an interview right right never pull
people towards your vulnerability I mean
I hate my my short stubby legs you know
what I mean just really focus on them
um
but yeah I I hated myself I was never
good enough nothing's good enough women
do this all the time we pull ourselves
apart you know I'm not funny enough I'm
not clever enough I'm not pretty and if
I'm not sexy enough all these things
this body is amazing and I spent all of
those years just hating it because it
wasn't what I wanted it to be but you
are not your body
you know I was talking to my family this
weekend I I lost an older sibling a few
years ago
and we were talking about when people
pass
and you know and suddenly he died of
cancer and we know in the last ages
people with cancer it's it's awful to
see them in that way but I don't
remember him in that way I remember the
essence of him I remember how funny he
was and how naughty he was and and it's
not I don't I don't remember anything
physical you know and it's just we just
need to get away from this physical
being
what defines us [ __ ] off it's not what
it defines us we're so much more than
that and um I've completely forgotten
what the question was but I just got
caught up no no so it's so powerful and
um it was linked to it all all of that
sort of suppression and a
self-abandonment coming to a head in
2020 2000 yeah yeah so exactly and I I'd
spent is like trying to make myself
smaller you know fit into the form that
I should be to be doing the thing that
I'm doing and it was killing me and I
know this is why I started talking about
my body because I'm so grateful to my
body
because it took over and it's and it
said to me we can't do this anymore
you're not doing this anymore we are
taking the control away from you and it
was hard because
from being very restrictive with my
eating and being anorexic I started
binge eating
because my body it couldn't help anymore
it wasn't getting enough fuel and I was
depressed I didn't know I was depressed
I had no I'd never even crossed my mind
that I had depression I just knew I'd
lost control over my eating and freaked
me out because it was all about the way
I looked you know it was it was vanity I
was like [ __ ] I'm eating I'm eating
loads and you know I feel very grateful
I was never bulimic I tried I couldn't
make myself sick and I'm so grateful for
that because I know it's a really
difficult illness to recover from
so I was getting bigger and bigger and
bigger because I was eating more and
more and more
um and then that was it was the vanity
that took me to the doctors as well as
being really [ __ ] scared because I
didn't know what was going on and I was
struggling to get out of bed and that
was when I was diagnosed with depression
and that was my first step on the road
to recovery you go to that doctor
who ultimately diagnoses you with
depression
can you remember that day vividly I do I
really do I remember sitting up to him
his desk
and I think I said everything out loud
for the first time but my eating about
crying and not being able to do that I
mean I didn't have the words I didn't
know what anxiety was I didn't know what
Depression was so what did you say to
him just because I want to get a color
of what the symptoms were that you
hadn't yourself pinpointed as well I was
I was tired all the time I couldn't
control my eating I mean I was I I
terrified myself because sometimes I'd
catch myself in mid-bench it was so it
was such a compulsive thing I'd like
yeah I'll just be in the middle of just
eating and I'd be like
you know and anyone and then suddenly I
know lots of people have these issues
it's like a cycle because you do it and
then you hate yourself
so you do it again and then you just it
just keeps uh you know getting worse and
worse and to the point where I had to go
to the doctor but I felt like I was
losing my mind I felt like I was
actually going mad and yeah and I didn't
have the right words and I know they are
not the right words that we use today
but those were the words I had
um yeah and he said
but first of all we have to
to do with your depression
I was like this weight was just lifted
from my shoulders because I was like oh
my God it's got a name it's something
that can be treated it's something you
can recover from and that was the
beginning of a very very long journey
very very long joke
I think I'm still on that Journey To be
honest I don't think
I think depression is always there it's
always waiting in the wings to looming
and well it is for me anyway
um but I'm quite good at just keeping
her Bay you learn the tricks and the
tools
for keeping it back
[Music]
you describe them I believe the
um the fear of that looming
um depression or you know I guess the
fear of going back to formal ways or
finding yourself in that situation has
has been quite a scary thing is it a
scary thing something you're you're
scared of
I don't want to Mis characterize your
words there but
um is it something that sits at the back
of your mind in terms of you know that
you fear there might be there it's like
a catalyst there could be one thing that
could yeah the thing I fear the most is
depression
because
you know I've I've always felt like
there's a fire in my belly and even you
know
mostly at my lowest of points
I can go this will pass
we can do this
but there are times within my depression
where I have doubted that
and
yeah
my biggest fear is it's that
you know really overwhelming depression
where you doubt if you can make it
through
Beyond it
you had you had those moments post
mainly where you didn't think you'd be
there was doubt whether you'd be able to
make it through a moment is this post
leaving the Spice Girls predominantly or
was their moments throughout the
experience where it's never we've never
officially split up is this bicycle oh
really yeah we took that decision
because
there was so much
press you know interest in us at the
time so you know I was really really
struggling we were working on forever
which is the third album as a full piece
without Jerry and I'd worked on my solo
records and I was having a really really
hard time and it was too much I found
the environment too much and I think the
girls knew me too well you know I was I
was dealing with these demons these
inner demons and they they could just
read me like a book and I just didn't
want to be in their company because I
had to do with it myself you know so I I
did want to leave the band
but we we took the decision to never
officially split up because we because
we didn't want the Press intrusion we
were terrified of because we know I mean
I slept at once on a TV show I did a
show with Frank Skinner and I used past
tense I said when I was a Spice Girl or
whatever the wording I used was
and the Press jumped on it and there was
camera Crews outside my house creating
and they chased me down the road and
yeah and it was just like
we couldn't none of us could face
and the you know the beauty of that is
now
we kind of feel like at the time we
needed separation you know we'd be in
like this our lives have been so
intertwined that we needed that space
but now we've had time to do that and
grow and become individual individuals
and mums and and have these Separate
Lives we can come back together and we
we really enjoy each other and respect
each other
so it'd be quite like that we've never
split up you know what I mean we've
always we'll always be faster when
people say formers but I'm not a former
Spice Girl I am a Spice Girl and we will
always always
even Victoria when she didn't go
downstairs to turn 19 she's still a very
very important part of that show
2019
you're you're you know
your account in your book about how
coming back together was actually a
really pleasant experience and it taught
you a lot about your previous time
together in the Spice Girls but let's
start with the point about Victoria then
a lot of lot was written about that
obviously when press do interviews
they're trying to twist your words and
find something wow how can we turn them
against each other like that's what
that's the game right
um so how did you all feel when you know
you knew that Victory wasn't coming back
to the group and you were going to be
doing it as a full yeah there was a few
feelings about that because obviously we
were gutted but you would be yeah
totally one of their and we were scared
because we'd go [ __ ] are people going to
want us it's a full piece
um you know in a different configuration
and the thing is you know
let's not you know well let's be honest
here Victoria is a huge International
icon you know she has gone on to be
something in her own right you know in
the Fashion World in the world of
celebrity she's much bigger than the
others of us individually
um I don't think anything's as big as
the Spice Girls you know we all feel
that but without her it's like people
gonna take us seriously
um so yeah so there was there was
different feelings around it the the
wonderful thing about it when she was
very supportive and it was really
important for us to make sure she was
happy so she was involved creatively you
know we wanted us to sign everything off
we wanted her to know exactly what we
were going to do
and it was such an incredible experience
I it felt like she was part of it anyway
why didn't you I didn't I missed the
story at that time but why didn't she
want to be what was her public statement
what was the reason public statement is
because of family and commitment okay
which is completely you know
understandable
um but I think you know on a more
personal level and I think this has been
said I don't think she'd mind me saying
when we did the Olympics in 2012 yeah
she had a really hard time it was she
was petrified I mean we were all bloody
petrified but to the point where it's
worth it yeah yeah yeah but I think it
was it so you know it was you had a lot
of anxiety and on that performance that
she was like you know what girls I'm
putting my dancing shoes up
um away so yeah so we totally got you
know we respected her decision
um but yeah but we were still sad about
it but you know what we went on to have
the most successful tour we've ever done
and you know with her blessing sadly
without her but we did it and it was
incredible and it really is truly some
of my happiest Spice Girls memories one
of the things that I wish I'd asked Liam
Payne when I spoke to him about One
Direction and The the group dynamic and
then what happens when the group
are no longer making music at the time I
don't want to say split up because that
is a bit loaded but when they're no
longer together is
um
what happens in the outside world in the
media is people then start comparing the
like the post band successes and I think
this can be very very toxic because
you're then being compared against in
the case of like One Direction these
four five other four other individuals
you'll then sort of measured your life
then becomes measured against who did
the best after it was measured during as
you talk about in magazines where they
said who is the hottest and who is this
yeah exactly um but then post you've got
you know as it relates to One Direction
you've got Harry Styles who is just you
know Untouchable
and I and I wonder like no matter how
how amazing the objective success is of
like another member are they they're
always compared to this person how true
is that in your case
um yeah it's true it's so hard it's so
hard to go on and become a solo artist
because you like this is what like
really drives me around about the media
right they tell you things you already
know
it's like you know interested in you
they just want the Spice Girls I know
um but no I mean that isn't totally true
but yeah yeah you're right it's really
really hard because you get compared so
much within the band and then post the
band but it's like you know you have you
have to have this logical brain don't
you where you go
how do we measure success you know for
me the hours of my life I am so happy
I'm so successful and there are all this
they need a bit of work but I think as a
fully grown adult you have to go stop
comparing yourself you know other people
might want to do it but you can't do it
we all do it we all look on Instagram
we've got our life's amazing [ __ ] no
one's life is amazing
you know there's a thing going on so I I
think yeah it's just we go off don't be
a little tangent sometimes but it's just
to just come back home and yeah
concentrate on the important things when
you when you went on the reunion tour
what did you learn about your former
experience from that tour
Ireland it was a shame that we couldn't
fully appreciate it at the time because
and you're never going to change history
and you're never going to change things
moving forward because
it's so chaotic I knew at the time that
you'll just be a little bit survival
mode you know you just kind of equates
going through the motions you know I
meet younger artists now like I've been
lucky enough to meet Billy Alice a few
times
I
relate to her so much I think I saw her
perform at Shepherd's Bush Empire and
she was already way too big to be
playing that incredible venue and all
these predominantly teenage girls were
screaming for her screaming at hair and
singing her songs and it just made me go
back to the Spice Girls shows I know
she's very different as an artist but I
just kind of felt this kinship with her
and so at times I just look at her and I
kind of feel like I I know what she's
feeling
and what she's going through so whenever
I have the opportunity to see her I just
kind of have this little connect with
him she was like
why does that make you emotional
because this incredible thing that
happens to you and it's so hard to
appreciate it because it's it's so
intense you know
because that experience was so
tumultuous for you because there were so
many difficulties as you approached the
reunion was their fear of you know the
former issues as well as the good times
but also the bad times coming with that
always whenever us girls get together
there's little triggers you know and I'm
scared but I have to face them because
you know I've learned to experience if
the other things I've gone on to do with
the girls we reunited in 2007 Olympics
2019
face the fear and actually beautiful
things happen so yeah and you know we're
much more mindful of each other now as
well because you know everyone had their
[ __ ] to deal with you know it wasn't
pain selling for anyone
was that too much of the reason you were
inspired to write your book
yeah it totally was I mean you know
sometimes I still question it I'm still
questioning it as this week
I I just felt I started to feel like
my soul is incredible you know I I'm
just I'm just a girl I'm a noble girl
from the north west working-class
background and I have a my dreams and I
go on to work in this industry work as
an international artist I mean it blows
my mind when I think about what I've
achieved what I've continued to go on to
do and and I want to inspire people and
I've gosh I've had hard times you know
I've had times when I thought I don't
know if I can carry on I don't know if I
can carry on in this industry I don't
know if I can carry on in this life
good afternoon and and I just really
hope that people can read this book and
have a laugh you know there's been some
funny bits there's some great memories
but be inspired and also find some hope
within it because you know I have
I I personally for me feel like I've
been at Buck bottom
at a time but I've worked my way up back
up to like feeling okay
I'm feeling great sometimes
so yeah I know I know people lots of
people struggle with some of their
issues that I've had to deal with
what stops you from writing this book
sooner
a bit scared a bit scared to go back to
those times I knew it was going to be
hard it was actually harder than
um really yeah and recording the audio
book which is something I definitely
wanted to do
that's a lot it's a lot because I think
to write those words is one thing but
then to speak them is something else
um you can be interviewed and talk about
these situations but kind of go through
it chronologically is is really really
draining yeah you've just been right um
reading the audiobook out in the studio
you sit there alone in these um
audiobook recordings in a small room is
that as a same experience and you read
through this this book that you've just
written
um what was the hardest part for you to
read
I'm only halfway through okay I haven't
even got to the really tough but yeah
um but you know what's weird I wonder if
you would find this too sometimes it's
the things you don't expect to get yeah
get yeah I got really upset the other
day when I started reading apart I I
can't even remember which bit it was but
it really surprised me because I know
there's like chapter 14 is it like
ingrained in my brain chapter 14 is when
I talk about my eating disorders and and
depression and and the Really lowest
point
um of my life
I know that's going to be hard to read
I've not got there yet
um but
yeah some of the other points have been
quite emotional and is that is that part
hard to read and recount now because
because of those feelings you described
earlier where you have the sadness for
that young version of yourself and you
you also said anger is that why it's
hard to even read it out now
I'm curious to see how I'm gonna do
because
I think I've built up like this
resilience to it as well because I I've
spoken quite openly in the media about
depression and eating disorders and I
actually started talking about it
probably before I was ready
because at the time I I felt like you
know being the Spice Girl it felt like
it was your duty that our lives were in
the public domain
and you know it was such a weird time
because there were so many things going
on you know there was so much exposed
about myself and other people in in the
entertainment industry
um because of phone hacking you know
there were so many secrets and things
that probably would never have made the
papers but you know they were listening
to people's messages we know that this
is a fact
so yeah there was this I felt like I had
to spill my guts and I was still very
vulnerable and I feel very ill you know
I wasn't anywhere near
on the road to recovery you know it was
just the very beginning for me
so I've had to build up the Earth this
wall around me so I I wonder whether I
can speak about that now and it not
affect me emotionally I'm curious
is that all a good thing
I think it's a necessary thing you know
yeah I think some of the other points in
the book you know are talking about my
childhood and my parents and
and they're quite new things I'm not
really discussed them openly before
um so they're quite hard and also going
to affect other people that's what's
been hard about this book it's not just
about me that's like Fame right Fame
just doesn't happen to you does it it
comes to everybody around you and they
do masquer it so and then the girl kicks
in again there's a lot of guilt attached
to fame I think
I had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast for many years
people have been asking for a coffee
flavored Hill and quite recently he'll
release the iced coffee caramel flavor
of their
um ready to drink Hills and I've just
become hooked on it over the last couple
of weeks I've been on a really
interesting Journey with huel which I've
described and talked about a little bit
on this podcast I started with the berry
ready to drinks then I moved over to the
protein salted caramel because it's 100
calories and it gives you all of your
essential vitamins and minerals but also
gives you the 20 odd grams of protein
you need and now I'm balanced between
them both I drink mostly the banana
flavor ready to drink I've got really
into the iced coffee caramel flavor of
heels ready to drink and now I'm
drinking that as well as the protein
make sure you try the new ready to drink
flavors that the caramel flavor is
amazing the new banana flavor as well is
amazing and obviously as I said the iced
coffee caramel flavor has been a real
Smash Hit so check it out let me know
what you think on social media I see all
of your tags and Instagram posts and
tweets about Hill where is your line in
terms of sharing stuff this is something
that I always think about
um obviously I have a podcast so I talk
a lot about my childhood and all the
things that happened and I've always
wondered you know there's being
transparent and honest because it will
help others that have gone through that
experience and that's really important
that's how we all learn you saying one
thing can quite literally save lives but
where is your personal line in terms of
because you kind of alluded to it there
where there's things where you just
can't maybe it's not the right time or I
think you know what's really important
with this book is it's my story and it's
in my words and it's my perspective and
I think the line for me is you know it's
not my place to tell other people's
stories
and you know to the point of hurting
other people
that that's I can't I I couldn't live
with myself
um but I know sometimes we hurt people
unintentionally you know so that's
probably my fear around the book coming
out now
um it's not my intention to hurt anybody
I've tried to be very careful
um but obviously like your parents
reading how you feel about things you
know that's that's gonna hurt
one of the things as well that
fascinated me was um your relationship
with with money you know um and
this
this suggestion that you had almost
guilt for your success
a few times on this on this um podcast
and it always seems to come from people
that have a working class background
can you tell me about that in your from
your perspective I think for me it's
it's I
oh you know really hard whatever you
know world's day working it can be
manual labor it can be you know I mean
my dad God bless him he's in his 70s
he's still traveling around the world
like a young man and doing this crazy
job and doing super long hours
and you know that my dad loves his job
but it's you know it's a necessity to
work that hard to put food on the table
to pay the bills right I
my my work can be hard it can be
grueling but I go on stage and I sing
and it's my passion and I'm very lucky
to do it and sometimes I could maybe
earn in a day what people in my family
might earn in a year you know and and so
there's guilt attached to that when I'm
when you think about the the thing that
made you successful the first time
around you you talk about it a lot that
and I talk about it as well that
insecurities were one of my biggest
drivers they were this you know you're
trying to fill some kind of void and you
end up it ends up resulting in
perfectionism and overworking and all
those things how do you control that
sort of those inner insecurities that
I could probably ask this question in a
different way those things that drove
you then yeah which ultimately are quite
unhealthy and toxic and and creating a
lack of balance in one's life how do you
stop those things driving you now how do
you stop being toxic driven
you know what I think partly age does
that for you because you're so exhausted
right yeah we've got the energy you're
right it could be that you know I I
think the thing is you know we live and
learn don't we and I'm a mum now so I
have a different set of priorities I
love my work sometimes I get the balance
completely wrong you know I'm with the
book and everything my workload is huge
right now this is school holidays you
know I'm not around enough for my
daughter so eating me up inside but you
know I I will find the time and we've
got holiday funding and I I think it's
just kind of learning from past mistakes
that you know be driven but not to the
point where it's detrimental the biggest
mistake I made is a real person person
whereas I believed other people knew
better than I did
no one knows better than you about you
just listen
like I spent so much time this weekend
with like really young people in front
of me and and I just look at them and I
just think just don't lose the essence
of you
you know because it because I think when
you're a kid I mean obviously people
have different circumstances but this
essence of you has all the answers it's
all you need you know and then life
comes in and just like
makes it all a bit out of balance so I
just like really encourage young people
to just really you know trust their
instincts I'm really I've been really
I've been thinking a lot about that
lately I've been thinking because when I
go up on stage and I try and give people
advice you know sometimes people will
often sometimes over complicate the
answer but as I've like looked back at
my own life and what I'm hearing from
you as well is that I I knew the answer
the whole time but there was a narrative
that persuaded me to ignore it so
sometimes that can be your your
immigrant parents telling you to go and
become a doctor or a lawyer when you
really want to just dance and so you you
kind of place their narrative over the
top of your own feeling and so and then
the other one can sometimes be social
media which tells you that you should be
an ex or a y or a z but inside of you I
think it's really liberating to consider
that you might already have all the
answers if you just listened
and tuned out these other voices
super easier said than done almost
impossible yeah and I think the fingers
as well it's like because you think it
can't be that yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
maybe maybe especially if the answer is
happiness if it is material success then
maybe you should go and be a doctor but
if it is happiness which I think is the
answer in in the long term if you don't
want to avoid a midlife crisis when
you're in your doctor's suit at 14 you
go what the [ __ ] am I doing here
whatever maybe that is the approach to
take but yeah that's what I'm saying
life is a series of chapters right
so what's right at one point
might change
so I think that's you know that is the
thing as well it's like okay a decision
might be made and you're following a
path and then at some point you're like
you know what this isn't working for me
anymore so you can change
I think that's I think that's really
powerful to know I mean it's [ __ ]
scary and not everybody has the luxury
of just going okay I want to change
right okay I'm gonna move back because
I'm going to gym no move country
whatever but I think what's powerful is
actually you have the power you just got
to find the way to do it yeah yeah the
practical way to
I think that's the most important thing
um one of the other things I wanted to
ask you about is when I reflect on my
own early upbringing with my parents and
and the model of love that they taught
me
not all great what impact did the model
of relationships and separation of your
parents have on your own model of of a
relationship and love if any I think the
biggest impact that
moment relationship and breakdown of
their relationship and my childhood is
telling me is that I yearn for a family
I yearn for that security
um and I I have a little girl I'm not
with her dad and that was really
difficult because I didn't want for my
little girl what I've done to me
um so yeah I I think I'm always I'm
always looking for that that environment
that I don't feel like I've ever really
had
we have got one last question for you so
the last guest asks a question for the
next guest but they don't know who
they're asking the question to
so they write a question in the book I
don't see it on my mother's life I don't
see it until I open the book
um
that was the last question okay here we
go
interesting
hmm
[Laughter]
this is interesting because it's a
question we've we've been asked once
um
before so it's interesting that it's
come up twice
um what is a pain
that you enjoy having ah
ah okay this
this
um I've had a little emotional turmoil
recently
and I was in the gym and I was
stretching to the point where it hurts
but it felt good
and I think sometimes and this is a
little bit self-harming I think like
physical pain sometimes will alleviate
like you know when I'm exercising to the
point of it hurting can help with my
emotional pain
you know exercise is a really
interesting thing because
you know obviously I have a
difficult relationship with it in a
sense because I did used to exercise
obsessively which I don't anymore but I
do exercise a lot and I do it
for my head more so than my body at
times you know it's really really
important to me but I can feel so low
and so tired and so lethargic and I can
go to the gym and I'm a changed person
you know you know it's it's like a it's
a miracle drug right whether it's the
endorphins the serotonin that's produced
whatever happens it's like when people
say to me oh you know how do you
encourage people to do exercise and it's
like
listen just go no pressure say I'll do
10 15 minutes and a better you there for
an hour
agree
that is when I was first when that first
ques when that question first came into
this book my immediate response was
exercise and I've never really thought I
I was always curious as to whether there
was an element of like escapism there as
well and I I'm always conscious about
escaping issues or
um and then when you refrained it when
you described it then as you're going
through an emotional pain and the pain
of the exercise almost helps to relieve
that
quite a curious thing because I
understand the endorphins and all the
chemicals and stuff but the pain itself
being a medicine is an interesting
concept
yeah it's like that thing is running
away you know if you're running no one
can catch you you're running you're
running right but it also makes you
great present you know when you are
running you are present and I've
actually done a lot of problem solving
when I've been running
had some little epiphanies as well so
it's I think exercises you know we were
built to move let's do it
Melanie thank you so much thank you so
much thank you so much and your book is
um truly important I think that's the
best the best way to describe it because
because the depth of your honesty and
the uniqueness of your experience offers
means that it offers so much to so many
people and even someone that obviously I
mean there's probably not there's
probably almost no one on planet Earth
that can relate to the experience itself
but the lessons that are within your
book and the lessons that you've managed
to pull out of those experiences are
lessons that we can all use to change
our life and I said to you before we
started recording that I usually don't
make that many notes and I just I made
way too many and it's really because I
had so I gained so much from reading it
about you know even my own life having
not walked in your shoes that um really
helped me in so many ways and I know
that everyone listening to it is going
to gain so much from it but I also
really have to specifically thank you
for your honesty around the eating
disorders and your depression because
that will quite literally save people's
lives and you may never see yeah you may
never you know get to hear directly from
those people but I assure you of that
it's it definitely definitely will so
well I thank you so much for saying that
because I've been honest in the
interview to say that I still fear
releasing this book but you know what if
it if that is the case and to hear that
from you then I feel good I feel good
about it I'm getting it out there
thank you
I had a few words to say about one of my
sponsors on this podcast crafted are a
brand that sell really meaningful
affordable men's jewelry and I've been a
crafted customer I think for about three
years now and all of the pieces that
crafted have created have deeper meaning
the piece of jewelry I wear the most I
want to introduce you to the pieces and
why I wear them is this sand timer
unsurprisingly and the thing for me
about sand timer is it's probably the
most clear reminder that our time here
on Earth is finite and when you live in
such a way where you can literally see
your time pouring away and you realize
that it is scarce and that we're not all
here forever you start to make better
decisions you stop worrying about
pettiness and trivialities that consume
Our Lives I always have this crafted
sand timer around my neck as a reminder
of that and this is why I wanted crafted
to sponsor this podcast because I can
use their meaningful jewelry every
episode to deliver a meaningful message
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]